[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom or life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host dr. Greg Sadler and today
we're talking about stoicism what it is
and it isn't
and this is a show that we decided to do
in part because we've we've referenced
stoicism so many times we thought it
could be useful to have a show just
about stoic philosophy and practices and
dan and I have both been involved in
that for quite a while we run the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship here which is
a branch of the much larger worldwide
stoic fellowship and you know we've each
been studying it on our own actually we
know each other largely I guess right
because of the stoic connection yeah I
saw the the meetup that you were running
I had went in and I said is this the
cynics you're like Stoics I'm like oh
yes that one yeah and then well I mean
you've been actually been doing more
than meetings with the stoic walk and
talks and then that maybe came what
stoic stoicism and the cafe and then now
that were entirely online because of
kovat 19 their online events right so
right you know it gets cold in the
winter I don't really like to walk in
the the early mornings and so yeah went
to the the cafe and now on we've been
going through what I'm Massimo Pigliucci
and Gregory Lopez's book what's it
called the handbook for new Stoics
that's so nice we should actually talk a
little bit about that before we jump
into the topic why now why did you pick
that book you tell me what you think and
then I'll tell you what I think about
the book so this is actually like an
expansion of just a really short
document that Massimo had put out on
some years ago was was just a whole
bunch of different stoic practices and I
found this one useful just because it's
it's got 52 weeks
practices and so it's just an easy way
to one if we're meeting weekly to have
some sort of easy structure so I don't
come up with a new lesson plan basically
every week or we're just saying talking
about the same stuff over and over as
well as it's it's it's easy to read it's
fairly straightforward and I found it to
be quite useful in thinking about things
in different ways that I hadn't before I
I like it I don't actually use it the
way it was intended and I got a review
copy before it came out so I got to see
it a little bit in advance and I was
like this is actually a really good book
it's it's well grounded it's got you
know tons of content that's helping
people understand stoicism so I actually
read around in it just sort of opening
it every once in a while to random
places and then I start at the beginning
of that that week and just read it
through and there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of really useful stuff in
there I think yeah it's it's definitely
a good source of practice so let's talk
about stoicism as a philosophy that
these practices are coming out of the
Stoics are one of the big schools of
ancient philosophy along with the
plaintiffs and the Aristotelian 's and
the Epicureans and the skeptics we call
them the Big Five and all of them
offered at least what people understood
back in ancient times a philosophy is a
way of life a way to put things into
perspective a way to understand yourself
and others in the universe and to work
on yourself and your problems so you
would have a better life and they they
disagreed to some degree on how you
ought to do that and what values you
ought to place as you know most
important or above all others but they
they all have this in common what comes
to be identified later on by Michel
Foucault is the care of the self and
it's not a selfish care it's a let's
make yourself less of a screwed-up
person
so you're not only happy yourself but
also less of a pain to everyone else sir
how do you and you can fit into your
society and be if not necessarily
productive at least not get in the way
of everybody else
right the philosophical project of
looking towards eudaimonia or translated
as either happiness or a fulfilling life
yeah and and so we should talk about to
begin with when we hear this word stoic
it's sort of like epicurean or you
mentioned the word cynic these terms
have changed quite a bit over the
centuries and what people call stoic
today isn't necessarily the same thing
as what stoic philosophy and practice is
consistent so this is a beginning
obstacle for many people they come in
with some idea that they've gotten from
our contemporary culture but what it
means to be stoic and they may be
attracted to it and think it's a cool
thing but then it turns out that they've
actually got it wrong sometimes this
this gets talked about as the difference
between lowercase s stoicism and
uppercase s stoicism or lowercase s
would be this you know keeping a stiff
upper lip what else fits in there it's a
you know think of Spock as your
quintessential straw snow a courier your
fake stoic here you know this idea of
what if stoic was I think on me for
those who don't know the original Star
Trek thing you got to tell him what
what's distinctive about Spock he's all
logic and no emotion whatsoever he finds
like emotion amusing or befuddling to
himself and you can't like figure that
out in his his worldview for the most
part unless he's he's got a you know
Captain Kirk to really you know lean on
or those tough to things right yeah Kirk
is always saying things like you know
it's not all chess it's it's poker you
have to play and then there's McCoy who
is a rather unbridled passionate person
you know
well well-known for the line dammit Jim
I'm a doctor not a XYZ
and and he's sort of the foil to Spock
but there's other things that that go
along with with stoicism as well the
notion that we should repress our
emotions I mean Spock
the Vulcans in Star Trek are kind of an
interesting Bunch because it looks like
they do have emotions but they found
ways to to suppress them or to to you
know
cognitively get rid of them except when
they of course go into heat I think and
then Spock is the interesting one
because he's like you know one foot in
two worlds he's half-human Welkin and so
he doesn't have the ability to deal with
his emotions as well and so they
sometimes overwhelm him that's true yeah
and so he we get to see through his eyes
these struggles to be a true Vulcan and
yet he doesn't want to lose what the
humans have to offer right as part of
the wisdom but you know we see people
talking about stoicism as if it's like
embodied by say sports figures or
soldiers people who endure pain and
aggravation and don't don't complain and
that's that's I mean you could be a
capital s stoic and do some of those
things but you wouldn't do it just for
its own sake there there would have to
be some point to resisting and enduring
and doing all of those sorts of things
so I think that's that's an important
thing to clarify but then that doesn't
actually tell us well what's the upper
case s stoicism and - before we move on
really quick to seal in in the
descriptions we have of antiquity about
our classic Stokes
we have them described as rather happy
and this is kind of you know at odds
with this idea of like this you know
stoic and a little less stoic you know
emotionless person you know you don't
think of someone who's rather jolly yeah
the the notion of them being kind of
grim and our you know
even Kaito Kaito the younger who is sort
of like a stoic hero and some people
even say maybe he was a sage a wise
person he was bold and daring when he
was a kid there was this guy who had
taken over Rome Sola and Sola this is
before the time of Julius Caesar who
Cato fought against and then you know
lost he was on the losing side of it
Sola was it he oh well I mean in terms
of the war he's certainly yeah yes he
lost the war yeah and you didn't lose in
terms of virtue
you're quite right about that Caesar was
always kind of a loser if we want to
think about it in those terms and and
Cato and Cicero who both fought against
Caesar with this other you know rum-dum
you know Pompey who was no great guy
himself but at least was you know trying
to try to maintain the Republic however
bad it was but going back to so so low
right so low was a military dictator and
Cato was a young guy and I forget
exactly who he was the word of but Cato
asked for a sword and they're like what
are you gonna do with the sword he's
like I'm gonna go kill the tyrant and
they're like you you're gonna do what
and he's a I'm gonna go kill sulla and
they're like you're joking no no I'm not
joking about it oh I'm gonna go kill him
why would you do that he's gonna kill
you yeah but it's the right thing to do
you know and he's you know quite into
this this idea and then they're like
okay don't let that kid around the
swords anymore so you know it's not just
joy but also the willingness to take
risks and we could also talk about love
to you know that's we don't think of
Stoics in the lowercase s sense as being
loving but Epictetus talks about
familial affection all the time Marcus
Aurelius talks about loving other people
Seneca does and you know they had a
place for it right and I maybe we want
to jump around here and go down to the
idea of emotions sure judgments yeah
yeah our classification thereof yeah and
you
wanted to say something I know about how
and this is completely you know
appropriate here how the Stoics viewed
the emotions in terms of appearances and
ascent so so why don't you start with
that and I'll talk about the
classification of them so you know a lot
of times we think of emotions like they
happen and then like they're valid it's
like yes they they do happen and I like
to think about emotions as they come
upon us like sneezes we don't ask for
them they just arrived it's how you deal
with it
that that's the important point and so
the Stoics try to yeah you have
something I like that that that analogy
actually because you're right most of
the time when we sneeze it's something
that just kind of happens to us and we
don't realize it but you can induce
yourself to sneeze if like you take a
bit of snuff or pepper and I think some
people kind of do that with emotions
like they watch certain things so they
can feel certain emotions and horror
films right well sure that's a great
example or you know people watching
things with the romantic romance yeah
yeah or watching reality TV so they can
despise people you know look at those
scumbags there so I think that's
completely right and I think there's we
could say that there's environments sort
of like when we when we go out and we
know we've got allergies and something's
gonna make us likely to sneeze like in
my case oak pollen of all things right
if we place herself into situations
where we're likely to run into emotional
allergens
maybe there's there's even more to the
the idea so I really like that that
analogy yeah and and so you know the
souks take this you know impression of
the emotion happening upon us as our
sneeze here and say okay we have in a
moment before we decide that we're going
to assent to this emotion and that that
moment is usually looked over but is
there is a place for reflection and and
once you have taught yourself that's you
don't have to immediately assent or you
know give into these emotions as they
appear to you you can give yourself the
ability to say is this a good or bad
thing for me on does it actually result
in my you know a good outcome yeah and
so that that's a good jumping off point
for talking about how the Stoics
classified the emotions and you might
say well why do cares about that right
we know what the emotions are mad sad
glad disgust you know I saw inside out
well there's more than just five
emotions you know even even for
psychologists who want to talk in terms
of really basic emotions today they
recognize more than five and the Stoics
thought that there were four big you
might call them buckets or modalities of
emotion and each of these had to do with
what Dan was just talking about
judgments so judgments about things
being good or bad and whether the thing
was there and you're faced with it right
now or whether it's it's often the way
so if we see something as good then the
general modality for that if it's
present is joy or pleasure or however
you want to talk about and the stoic
said there's a lot of different things
that fit into there and the kind of love
that we talk about is romantic love
might might fit into that to some degree
and then there's the good that's not yet
here but which we can orient ourselves
towards because when we see something is
good we kind of like reach out to it in
our minds or our our souls and so that's
desire and desire can take a lot of
different forms it's really interesting
that the Stoics placed anger in the
category of desire because it's it is a
desire it comes from pain but it's a
desire to make somebody else suffer in
return for what they did to us and they
they actually through a couple different
kinds of anger into that bucket because
there's so many different ways in which
people are angry but you know we could
also talk about like sexual desire or
the desire to be filthy rich you know
greed or things like that and this the
Senecas on anger yeah yeah that's a
great book by the way for anger
management stuff and then you know in
the in the realm of things that we we
think are bad or evil and we don't want
to have to deal with or to suffer if
it's right there present then we call it
pain lupe in greek right or disturbance
being bothered by things and it could be
annoyance it could be grief it could be
actually feeling sad there could be all
sorts of things and then the things that
we we don't we recognize as bad but
they're not yet here the general
orientation to that is fear and fear can
take all sorts of forms as well and so
the stoic said that's you know that's
where the at least the majority of our
emotions come in some of them send all
the emotions fit into that those four
classes there's a little bit of
difficulty about where to put some of
the other emotions that get brought up
but we don't have to go too deep into
that but here's here's part of the
upshot these emotions many of them can
be bad for us and you know they they
don't feel great to feel and they also
lead us to doing dumb things when we go
along with them like the Stoics thought
that anger was in general not not good
for us and and it's not gonna be good
for other people too because we're gonna
we're gonna do stupid things or
imprudent things unjust things but there
could be some rational ways of feeling
emotion so the Stoics and here's where i
think you know we might disagree with
them as modern Stoics but they thought
that at least with three of these kinds
of emotion we could feel them in a
rational way so think about fear for
example they said that there's a
rational kind of fear caution so you
know if I'm walking out in front of the
bus and the bus is barreling down it on
me at like 55 miles an hour I probably
ought to feel a little sense of
self-preservation that says Oh get out
of the way right if I don't there's that
I'm gonna get squash
like bug and that's not gonna be good
for me and it's probably not gonna be
good for all the people depending on me
certainly not gonna be good for the poor
bus driver who's going to be traumatized
as a result or the passengers and you
know so there's you know and there's
there's all sorts of things that we can
rationally fear it's within the the
scope of reasons so it's not fear that
like washes over us and reduces us to
nothing and we can do is to try to
maintain that reason as kind of leash in
that emotion I guess that's a good way
to put it yeah and maybe guiding it to
like telling maybe reason tells us fear
this thing don't fear this thing you
know like you get bit by by let's say
you're out and you know playing around
in the yard or something and you get bit
by a spider you might feel you know
twinge of fear at first then you're like
oh my gosh I'm gonna die well reason to
tell you no you're not gonna die from a
spider bite it's not a you know black
widow it's probably not even a brown
recluse and we don't have any other
poisonous spiders here it's gonna hurt
you know maybe it's gonna get you know
discolored or something and swell up but
you're not gonna die buddy even if it's
a big scary hairy tarantula you know
they don't carry that much that much
venom so so that would be an example and
and I think that you know by rationally
into having an integration of reason and
that emotion of fear it can it can help
us to avoid doing a lot of dumb things
and also help us to keep a sense of
perspective about what we need to
protect you know and then in the last
one yeah well then there's there's
rational desire right and and they
called that it's a hard to translate
term it's boule Asus they translate it
as wish but it's more like the stuff
that it makes sense for us to desire so
the Stoics in ancient times were pretty
you know you call them sticklers about
marriage i think that they would say
that within the scope of marriage you
ought to be having an exhibiting and
following sexual desire
they weren't grilled big on doing things
outside
that but it makes perfect sense there or
you know if you stop desiring eating and
drinking well you're gonna die you know
and then they also thought that there
could be rational joy you know feeling
feeling the right sense of positive you
know appreciation of the good in front
of us the thing that they thought there
couldn't be any rational version of is
pain or or suffering I I don't entirely
agree with them on that myself I think
sometimes it's it's it's okay for us to
feel grief but you know and Seneca says
this too he just says well you got to be
rational in your grief right you don't
like you know bust up the place and tear
your beard out and rend your clothes
like all those crazy people or you know
stay in mourning for two years after
somebody dies you know you you you you
mourn them but you do so in a in a way
that's that's befitting and I kind of
want to bring this back to like a lot of
times people will make the argument like
oh the souks don't care about emotions
and and I wouldn't push back against it
like you know your emotions happen
because there is something that elicited
them in the first place yeah and this is
at the very least so that's information
and like you know that you've got
fearful doubt something and so maybe
it's a stick on the ground and maybe
it's a stick or maybe it's a snake yeah
but you know you don't know until you
actually look at the stick and realize
this is stick or not and not a snake and
yeah and so it - basically all emotions
are there is something that you know our
our brain has defined as a Miss and we
need to deal with it to some extent and
how you deal with it is is kind of up to
you but but only if you are like looking
at it and not just giving into it in the
first place because if it's a stick and
you see it and you turn around and run
away and scream and holler it's probably
not the best way to deal with that for
instance yeah our emotions
are integral to how we take in the world
and also how we approach other people
you know and they can be you know like
well oriented or well calibrated and
perfectly appropriate or they can they
can lead us astray quite a bit and I
think we by the time that we start
thinking about this we're usually kind
of screwed up if not really screwed up
and usually we're not like totally
screwed up but you know more screwed up
in one way and less screwed up in
another way and then you know you know
we can we can work on these things if we
want to we can start looking and I guess
this fits in with stoicism as well
something that that the Stoics talked
about it gets translated is
attentiveness or sometimes mindfulness
Pro so hey and Greek like paying
attention to what you're doing and that
doesn't just mean paying attention to
what's happening with your body it means
paying attention to what your thoughts
are and and how the thoughts are
connected to each other so if you if you
notice that you keep on feeling a fear
that disables you in certain situations
that might be assigned to you I need to
check up on this and figure out why I've
associated I don't know drinking tea
with this horrible fear that I have in
the pit of my stomach right going back
to the snake thing I was actually
laughing because I was just thinking of
two things one was when I used to work
as a security guard late at night when
you're you know when you're
sleep-deprived you start to see things
that aren't there in the things that are
there and a stick for a snake is really
common a bush for a deer is another
really common thing too and I was
thinking about that that experience that
I had and then I was thinking about
another thing too so let's see it
actually is a snake well it might not be
a poisonous snake if it's just a you
know a little snake it's probably not
going to hurt you but what if it's a
giant like Python or boa constrictor
that may actually be an opportunity
because now here's you know this is not
going to peel to everybody
you know if you had some big boa
constrictor out in the wild you know
that was eyeing you up you could also
eye it up and the great thing about
snakes is if you like ribs
snakes are all ribs yeah that's a little
bit off-topic yeah so why is there been
this revival like you know this is a
kind of fell away for you know several
hundred years over a thousand years I
guess the last big revival it wasn't
like the sixteen hundreds maybe yeah I
mean it was never it was never a totally
across the culture kind of thing they
are always a minority but all the
philosophical schools were - in
antiquity but they had a significant
representation enough to actually like
get exiled every once in a while for
being Stoics so that tells you that they
were taken seriously
and a lot of stoicism got absorbed into
another philosophical school of
Neoplatonism who ended up saying you
know Plato got the sort of top-level
metaphysics right and either the Stoics
or the Aristotelian 's got the bottom
level stuff about the world in the body
right so we're gonna blend them together
there's there's quite a bit of that one
of the great commentaries on epictetus
in the ancient world is by this guy
simply kiyose who's trying to take
Epictetus and karidian epictetus you
know for our listeners is one of the
very important stoic figures in the in
creating is one of the beginner texts
that we often start people with it means
the handbook and so simply kiyose is
bringing all these playtest ideas into
it and and also sort of glomming the the
stoicism in there and then you know that
made its way into Western monasticism if
you look at the theorists of that like
John Cassady and there's a lot of stoic
stuff in there and so I think in a way
you know it never completely died but it
was there as something that was absorbed
into other other systems of thought and
of life and then there you're right
there's this revival in the Renaissance
they start you know they get Marcus
Aurelius as met
Asians from the Byzantines they they've
already had the Seneca laying around for
a long time because the monks actually
liked Seneca a lot so they they copied
all of his stuff and they they start
finding a few bits of other things as
well and it takes off like gangbusters
in the early modern period so you've got
these people like you know that are
quite attracted to it like miguel de
Montaigne there's lip seus who's what we
call a neo stoic trying to blend
together a certain kind of Christianity
and stoicism and I think you know really
all the way through the 18th century
people know knew who the Stoics were and
they so seriously so what's the most
recent revival you know the last 50
years I'd say the last like 25 and yeah
you're right there's there's earlier
works where mostly academic works where
people were talking about the Stoics but
the the one that really starts off the
the most recent revival and academics
would be the works by a long and then by
Lawrence Becker Lawrence Becker has this
book a new stoicism that many people
it's sort of like the Bible you know a
lot of people talk about it very few
people actually read it because it's
difficult and you got to figure out what
the hell he's talking about
but it's very rewarding and you know
that's that kind of put it those works
can put it on the scene and then other
people started saying maybe this could
be useful for ordinary life or for
productivity or for handling my emotions
and people started you know paying
attention to the the connections between
stoicism and the cognitive approach in
psychotherapy which would include not
just the very popular CBT cognitive
behavior therapy but the earlier
rational emotive behavior therapy of
Albert Ellis
and other similar approaches and then I
don't know it's sort of like a snowball
you know starts rolling downhill
gathering more and more picked up by
Silicon Valley
you got like Tim Ferriss and Ryan
holiday being like popularizers yeah and
and more and because it's being taken
seriously people who otherwise might not
have focused on it as much say oh I
could I can talk with other people about
this maybe there's you know a
conversation to be had and so they write
books and you know it leads to having
stoic cons and stoic week and all this
cool stuff that's going on to the
worldwide stoic fellowship and our
Milwaukee branch of it right so there's
all of that go in a blog or something
what was that called well you're telling
what the one that I edit right stoah
saying today I mean but there's a whole
bunch of other blogs out there as well
and podcasts and videos is there a radio
show right now I don't I don't know that
there is I mean we're talking a radio
show at the very least yeah and there
could be a stoical radio sometime in the
future that would be kind of a cool
thing to see maybe but there's a there's
a pretty wide range of both let's call
it expertise and practice and
commitments within the modern stoic
community so there there is no like
agreement on some things like the stoic
cosmology or the physics you know the
Stoics had some some views that I think
a lot of people don't accept today like
the whole universe is one living thing
that is really God and or reason or
however you want to put it and it's
private and conscious yeah so that's
kind of a big big ask isn't it I mean
what you know what would you say about
that well it's it's interesting because
I've had experience with the what do
they call the traditional traditional
Stoics as well as the the more modern
Stoics and and I definitely move towards
the the more modern Stokes in my
understanding of things yeah and you
know so it can appeal
to a lot of different people and I you
know another thing I think we could say
is a division within the stoic community
is the people who are committed to like
just a portion of stoic teachings when
it comes to the ethics and then the
people who are committed to like the
whole thing like you know we sometimes
joke around in the stoic community about
something that's not really stoicism but
what we call bro s ism which is the
people who emphasize the you know
fortitude or courage part and they use
some of the stoic concepts and
techniques but they're really mostly
about trying to become a super dominant
alpha person and that's that doesn't
really go along I mean there's other
things in the stoicism or they would say
so a system is lighter packs and instead
of actually as a philosophy of like life
exactly yeah and it you know I guess one
sort of hallmark and I know this is
something you wanted to talk about
stoicism says that our nature as human
beings is social and so anything that
tends to separate us and cut us off from
other human beings provided that they're
not you know morally vicious to the
extent that we can't really deal with
them we really should be suspicious of
so if my interpretation of stoicism says
that I need to be a tough guy who like
inserts myself into disputes and then
you know just stands there resolutely
you know fists clenched or something
like that that's probably a
misinterpretation grants and absolutely
agree that's kind of this idea of I
don't want to go into too much
considering how much we have to get
through but like the idea of living in
accordance with nature and and one of
those things is is living pro-social II
yeah and and what so if you're if you're
doing things that results in like
antisocial behavior then you're probably
going down the wrong path here yeah I
think I I think that's well worth
talking about actually I'm you know and
this is a great place to talk about the
virtues which my
put this in context because you know one
of the virtues that we've already
mentioned is courage or fortitude but
the Stoics think that it's not really
courage if it if it goes against another
one of the virtues justice and justice
has to do with you know what we what we
owe to other people and the Stoics are
really you know unequivocal about this
justice itself and our grasp on justice
comes about because of our social nature
because that's the kind of beings that
we are and and one of the other knocks
against stoicism is like but where's the
the benevolence and we the answer is
it's justice you know like are the four
cardinal virtues here wisdom justice
temperance and courage and you know
benevolence would be subsumed within
that justice it's a part of justice you
know we it is what we are supposed to be
doing to others and how should we be
dealing with them and if we are all part
of this you know greater whole that of
you know humanity or the rational beings
then when we attack another we are in
you know himself attacking ourselves you
know that's actually another really
important feature of stoicism that we
see in the text 11 but especially in
Marcus Aurelius right but also in the
other thinkers who we've we have been
shinned this notion goes work together
like two feet left and right with work
together like the upper and lower teeth
I can't work together you can't they
don't work if you don't work together
with them yeah and the notion to that if
if a part of the body or a part of any
sort of whole decides that it's the
thing that matters the most
it becomes no longer properly functional
and you know we're so used to thinking
of ourselves in very individualistic
ways and I think some of that is because
of our culture we're probably at a small
disadvantage being Americans
because there's so much stress on my
rights and my liberties and all that
that sort of thing but a lot of it I
think comes from from the emotions as
well a fear for example if I don't like
look out for myself nobody's gonna take
care of me so I've got to be you know
very self centered and don't give
anybody any opportunities just just you
know screw me over or anything like that
if we look at ourselves even when we're
in relationships that are flawed or you
know definitely non-ideal as being in
something that as you know like the the
phrase goes it sounds a little new agey
something bigger than us right and the
stomach's really did believe in that you
know like so you and I are friends for
example we're also like co-hosts of that
insofar as we're doing this there's
something that's more than just you or
me
there's the let's call it just the
relationship itself and that has some
value and that requires some nurturing
and that provides us with a kind of
orientation or perspective that allows
us to do this this activity that we're
involved with right here you know and
and I think we can look at so many other
things this way and this is where a lot
of relationships go bad and stoicism can
help us with relationships if we look at
the relationship primarily is this is
something you've talked about quite a
bit in the past zero-sum games but we
can also think of it like and what can I
extract from this relationship you know
if we look at if we look at things in
that sense where we're starving the
relationship where we're not allowing it
to to grow and we're hurting ourselves
in the process because you know we
according to the Stoics on some basic
level want to be connected with other
human beings and and maybe you know
maybe beyond that we maybe we want to be
connected with the rest of the world so
it kind of bringing it back towards
living in accordance with nature yeah
you can look at this as I believe
chrysippus puts it who is the the second
head of the school or is he the third
third third and he's a second bounder
exactly yeah yeah there you
it was because of his body of work and
he kind of divides it up into you know
you've got the nature of the University
we can think of that as like physics and
then you have this nature of living
things and so all living things have a
feeling of self-preservation and you
might want to you know extend to that if
you want a per serve a Shinto also
reproduction well in flourishing too
yeah yeah and and then we as humans have
an extra level of our nature which is
our nature of Reason which supervenes
which is that's a fancy word for meaning
that it's it comes after but it then on
changes the things that happen before it
and so first we have these are nature of
self-preservation and then and then we
have reason that can like change what we
would do so we're not just acting as I
guess otamatone is here yeah and so a
good example this would be like a parent
sacrificing their life for their child
like at first glance people are you
animals or whatnot would not want to
lose their life but we have some sort of
reasoned decision-making that says okay
this is actually more important for me
to do this then for me to continue
living yeah and and the reason thing is
really interesting and this doesn't just
apply to stoicism it's it's kind of an
across-the-board thing and it's not just
in Western philosophy too but also in a
lot of non-western you know like say
Indian or Chinese philosophy there's
this realization that human beings are
distinctive animals and part of what you
know what allows us to transcend our
merely animal nature but not become gods
or angels or anything like that
is this Faculty of rationality which
also includes speaking it includes like
our cognitive processes and stuff like
that but it's still rooted in our our
animality and
it also it not only can make us like
able to function well together and like
make plans and do all sorts of cool
stuff it also makes us the most
dangerous animals we can be the most
destructive we can if we if we don't use
it's not it's not like reason is just a
set of processors that automatically go
the right way because they've been
coated properly as a matter of fact you
know it's like coating that can recode
itself and often has all sorts of bugs
in it already there's massive lists of
cognitive biases and oh it's just
reasoning yeah you know where it takes
work to not that's it yeah
so so that that putting in the work
that's really central the stoicism right
right and and so virtue are those
actions that we have deduced through
reason to be those actions that result
in like the best ends both for our own
personal enjoyment of life are
eudaimonia but also for the are our
social position at an opposition but
like our social groups are those groups
of people that we care about and the
stokes would say that's that's all
rational beings we should mention what
the other virtues are too so I did oh no
I don't we should talk a little bit more
about that so we talked about about
justice quite a bit that it includes
benevolence and as part of our social
nature we and we've also talked about
courage I think but you know the Stoics
thought that wisdom was or prudence is
another way of putting it was absolutely
central and that we need to cultivate
that and they gave us all sorts of
techniques and insights for developing
that but also they talked about
temperance that's an old-fashioned word
we translate it nowadays often as self
control or moderation I'm not sure that
it it has quite the same tenor in those
how important do you think temperance is
for the stoic life
very uh you know work okay because well
I guess everything in moderation and you
know for example water is
life-sustaining but too much water is
toxic you know yeah and so goes with
most things in life you know you know
sex is pretty good but too much sex and
that's gonna make it so you're not doing
any of the other things that you're
required to do to be a good person in
your community
um and you know if you've got other
obligations and you're failing to do
them because that's all you're doing I
don't know well I think what particular
thing but that is a no that's a it is it
is a great example because we do live in
a society where although we've now
figured out that the advertising adage
that sex sells is actually wrong it it
doesn't actually help you to sell
products it if you have a sexy
commercial it does get people very
interested in sex and it's something
that that we you know it's constantly
being thrown at us because of you know
the fashion industry and our media and
the ubiquity of pornography and you know
you name it right and it and you're
right it can lead us to not recognizing
other values m'p out that drive that
again sort of distinctively human right
dogs are dogs won't have sex elephants
want to have sex none of them will like
spend hours on end you know doing all
sorts of weird things that cost them
lots of whatever the equivalent of money
is for dogs right trying to get you know
get involved with somebody else we do
that and that's that's partly where our
rationality is is our greatest strength
and our greatest weakness so if we don't
have that particular Drive in some
control you know
integrated to some degree with reason
we're really in a bad shape because it's
not just sex - it has to do with you
know the feelings of affection that go
with it and how people use it to be a
compensation for the
lack of other you know goods or
pleasures in their life that's it that's
a really major one same thing with food
you know it seems like a second ice
cream yeah it seems like a trivial thing
but man I'm a we're an obese nation so
you know there's clearly something going
on so so temperance is a very important
aspect of the stoic life should we talk
about the there was an interesting
question that I found in one of the
Facebook groups that I think fits in
well with what we're talking about yeah
and I think we'll have to come back to
this major topic again because we're
definitely going to do some more Sun
disables yeah yeah so somebody wrote in
and and you see stuff like this every
once in a while this isn't one of the
Facebook groups that after practicing
stoicism and he didn't say exactly how
long he was doing it he found himself
numb disengaged with little interest in
things and he expressed the worried that
that stoicism had damaged him and it
didn't take long before a whole bunch of
people weighed in and they're like buddy
you've been doing stoicism wrong and and
it might have been better to say you
haven't actually been doing stoicism
you've been doing something else in the
process so what would you some well I
mean the Spock thing maybe that wouldn't
be quite that bad but what you know
going just straight to Vulcans instead
of just Spock because he's got that
spark of emotion there still yeah but
yeah it seems like he's instead of
welcoming those emotions and observing
them and dealing with them he is just
stuffing them down so to the point where
he's not feeling anything that he's
getting to that numb space and it
doesn't seem like it's been particularly
good for him yeah and and I think people
do things like that sometimes because
they want to insulate themselves off
from a harsh outside world that seems
threatening or disappointing or however
painful however else we want to talk
about or maybe it's a way of dealing
with trauma
and it's dangerous to do in part because
habits do determine us so if you
constantly take your disappointment and
then just shove it down and then put on
a not necessarily a happy face but at
least an impassive face after a while
you lose the capacity to deal with that
emotion of disappointment to be able to
linger with it and say well what am i
disappointed about what a stoic would do
with disappointment for example is say I
feel disappointed that's an emotion I'm
having what's going on here
why am i why am I feeling it what are my
thoughts what are my judgments that are
leading me to feel this way are they
accurate or are they off-base and how
would I know the difference right and
it's the thing that I'm disappointed
about under my control or is it
something outside of my control yeah
there you go
or is it is it something that doesn't
really have any value all right all
right so and we could talk about all
sorts of other motives or spurs that
might lead a person to do this but I
think the force of habit
is something that we have to be really
attentive to and where we're thinking
about these sorts of situations so I
feel I kind of feel bad for the guy
that he probably created more work for
himself on his path to personal
development or you know transformation
towards happiness because it sounds like
he made himself pretty unhappy by doing
something that's you know sort of that
lower case s stoicism rather than actual
stoic teachings and now making progress
in the wrong direction oh that's a good
one yeah now is it progress if you're
going the wrong way
well there's you're progressing
sub-layer yeah I mean it feels like
you're making progress at the time but
then you need a sense of perspective you
need something like a map to get you you
know a map and a compass I suppose you
could say so that you know where you're
actually going right now if I feel bad
for that guy is that non stoic what do
you think you feel bad for him no
because I think you're wishing him to
have a
better outcome in his life later you're
desiring for him to have a more you know
happy you know fulfilling life and he's
definitely got it
not there yeah he's if not go on in the
exact opposite direction because at
least maybe he's developed some
self-control
you know he's certainly gone off of the
path and he's out in I don't know the
fields or called the sack or something
like that right yeah life is amazing
sometimes we hit those dead ends got a
double back a little bit that's an
interesting point of view to the notion
that we have to be able to recognize
when we've got things wrong I think
that's that's where maybe we can also
say genuine stoicism is something very
different than the impassive kind of
Stoicism that would like hide our mixing
things up right marcus aurelius over and
over again says hey if i've got things
wrong tell me I've got them wrong
because that might my goal is not to
like do things my way my goal is to
actually get things right or epictetus
constantly talking about you know who's
the slave and who's the master in this
thing you know if you were constantly
being tugged here and there by your
emotions or I guess in this case the
lack thereof and now he's getting a
motion of you know numbness I know is
that emotion or just a total lack of
emotion but it's definitely if it
doesn't feel good then you are you know
you're now a slave to this particular
position that's mine state that you're
in that's interesting so a part you you
would be a slave to a part of yourself
right but a part of yourself that
shouldn't really be running the show you
could say because the reasons supposed
to be the thing that's ultimately
running the show yeah well that's a I
think that's a good answer for that that
particular problem or
should we there now stoic practices I
think we could actually like do an
entire show just on practices right but
we had one in mind that we wanted to
that's right with the book yeah we had
one in mind that we wanted to bring up
that that's particularly useful for
people and you can start applying it
right away and it doesn't take an awful
lot to think about it and if you keep
doing it you'll get better and better at
it right mm-hmm
so there's different different ways of
talking about this some people call it
depersonalization which doesn't mean you
quit being a person but you quit making
everything about you right so yes this
is we tendency to tell ourselves that we
have to do that but not everyone else
does means that we're doing it
contingent but not necessarily yeah so
when we feel or think or react to
something we tell ourselves we have to
do that you know like I don't know for
me when somebody is driving slow on the
left lane that tends to tick me off I
don't does that bother you
oh it did until I lived in the sense of
the area and had to deal with all the
time just kind of like shed myself of
this thing because because otherwise it
would have killed you
oh yeah three hour commute every day
yeah okay
so I'm not at that point yet and I you
know if I get stuck behind somebody you
know I'll actually take action too by
the way I'll all like flash my lights
you know and sometimes like point get
out you know
get out of the road but if I told myself
that the feeling of irritation or
aggravation it's something that I have
to do I'm lying to myself why because
well I mean you'd be a perfect example
you don't do that right when you're
driving along and you know I 94 and some
idiot is in the the side lane and
they're going 55 which is the speed
limit and you know you're not supposed
to go the speed limit
Tan Lane you're supposed to be going at
least ten over right it's kind of a
weird unwritten rule but but it's
totally the rule there at least exactly
yeah and it's probably 10 because 11
miles an hour and that UPS you're at
least in Wisconsin the amount that you
have to pay exactly well the cops will
pull you over for ten over unless it's
not worth their time they'd like to see
you going ten over because then traffic
is flowing so so if I can say well when
this happens to Dan he doesn't do that
what does that tell me that tells me
that there's nothing in the nature of
things or nothing in the nature of me
that makes it necessary that I have this
reaction so you know like Epictetus
would say listen Socrates didn't fear
death so therefore you do fear death but
you don't have to fear death there's
nothing about the nature of you know the
world or human beings that says that you
have to do that but we can use it you
know this this trivial example as well
and when we realize that it doesn't mean
that we quit feeling it but now we have
some leverage we can we can talk to that
thought or feeling and say hey you're
not necessary you don't have to go that
way and then we can also gain a little
bit of leverage we can like start
looking at it and saying what's wrong
with me why do I do this why do I feel
this way what's what's going on and we
can start pulling at some of those
threads to undo that not right the whole
idea of like oh he provoked me doesn't
hold water in this case for it so that's
a good example why doesn't look like
here's an example I had this week and I
went to the grocery store and I walked
by a gentleman as I was walking into the
store and and we both were going to the
same section of the store to pick up
apparently both were picking only up one
thing I I get there first because I've
got a quite quick gait
McCann's I I pull my item and I turn
around and he's there and he's flipping
me off like and I'm just taken aback
I don't know what I did to provoke you
um but then I'm like okay well that's
his problem and it walked to the the
checkout and he comes up and he stands
right behind me in like there's several
wines but he could have chosen to go and
he sends some really close behind me and
he I feel like he's trying to provoke
some action out of me and I just yeah
and I turn around I just like oh man
it's so nice and spring and the weather
is starting to get so nice you can be
outside and I'm just like I need to
personalize myself to this person
because he's just seeing me as someone
that apparently is insulted I don't know
exactly has taken his thing there was he
it was definitely not that I think he
had a different item not to mention
there was a number of other duplicates
of the item that I had how interesting
yeah I I don't know but you know it was
the I could have been provoked and he
was doing things that for many people
would have provoked them and I realized
that I had the choice in that moment
even though my body was reacting I hope
the adrenaline goes through my body yeah
that I didn't have to do that angry
reaction there I could deal with this in
a totally different way yeah you know so
that's a great ending point stoicism is
something that is empowering it's it's
not something that subjects us and like
makes us statues or people who are you
know dour and and unhappy all the time
it's it's supposed to make us happier
right and I imagine there's there's a
sense of like not just liberation but
like oh I can actually do this that
comes with having that that experience
right yeah at the end of it was that he
he responded to me and at least you know
civil civil terms yeah and he backed up
a few paces you might have actually
helped them to I mean we'll talk much
more in other shows about all sorts of
ins and outs of stoicism but you never
know whether you plan to deceit in him
three noses so last thoughts all that
you have the last word as usual in this
show all right so here's a quote from
epictetus in his discourses people are
upset not by things but by their
judgments about those things
[Music]
[Music]
you